- But first I wanna talk
about the movie Encanto
because, well, it's all
we watch at my house.
My kids will not let me watch
anything else at this point.
I've seen it so many times.
I love it though.
That's what's helpful is when
people make movies for adults
and children at the
same time, it's awesome.
But there's another woman
who's become obsessed
with the film as well
after seeing how much she looks
like one of the main characters, Luisa.
So this is Luisa and this
is 23-year-old, Maribel.
(audience claps)
I was like, what?
That is amazing.
I was like the guy drawing her, see her
like it was, it was crazy.
But if you know the movie,
you know why it's also funny
that her real name is Maribel.
And I do know why, 'cause
I've seen it a lot.
It's really good though every time.
When Maribel discovered
the striking similarities,
she got creative and
posted this to TikTok.
♪ I don't ask how hard the work is ♪
♪ Got a rough and
destructive the surface ♪
♪ Diamonds and platinum. ♪
♪ I find 'em, I flatten 'em ♪
♪ I take what I'm handed ♪
♪ I break what's demanded ♪
(audience cheers)
(Kelly laughs)
- We have Maribel dialed in from Phoenix.
What's up, Maribel?
(audience cheers)
Oh my gosh, the resemblance is uncanny.
I loved you acting it
out, doing the whole song.
By the way, that's like
my kid's favorite song
and they like Bruno, We
Don't Talk About Bruno,
but they love that song too, Pressure.
But how did you put it together?
Did you see it or did
someone tell you about it?
- Well, people started commenting
that I looked like Luisa,
so I was like, wow.
And I was like, they're like
have you watched Encanto?
Have you seen the video?
And I was like, no, I haven't.
And so I was like, okay,
so I watched the movie
and I started getting comments,
like I watched the movie
and I was like, oh my goodness,
I see the resemblance.
And so, not only did I
not see the resemblance
but I've never seen a Disney
character look like me.
So, I was just so excited.
And it's crazy because in the movie
she carried the whole
world on her shoulders
and in this same place,
I felt the same way
'cause growing up, I
had to raise my siblings
from the age of six
'cause my mom had mental
health issues, so.
And then when I got older I adopted them.
So now I was like, wow,
I need to do this video.
- That's crazy how much you
can relate to the message.
That's amazing.
And you actually heard
from Luisa herself, right?
- Yes.
Jessica Darrow actually
she commented on my video and liked it.
And then, I ended up messaging her
and I was like I would love to meet you.
And she's like likewise.
And I was so excited.
- I love that.
Well, she did a fantastic job
and you did a fantastic job on TikTok.
Thank so much, Maribel.
God bless.